we know that reagan really didn't
respond to aids during the first five or
six years of his administration even
though in 1981
scientific evidence came out that we had
an epidemic
on our hands reagan really didn't
resources to the medical research in
this epidemic and really hasn't done too
much until recently he now has his
testing
programs but he's never really responded
to it as a medical
problem is there any evidence that the
cia
or some reaganites might be involved in
the origin of aids that first didn't
really appear
until around 1981 is this the sort of
virus that can be concocted by
chemicals or some sort of biological
warfare techniques well there
are articles have been written by
doctors saying that this thing
smells of a man-made virus
and mentioning this fort dietrich where
so many experimentations have been done
and
in devising uh biological
uh warfare and the diseases that can be
controlled can be used on society
no evidence has come out nothing that
can be cited as proof
and so we can only raise the question
and i
i have the feeling that if there is
evidence somewhere if there was it's
been destroyed
another suggestion not cia and mind you
in the context the fort dietrich
experimentation in the context of the mk
ultra program of experimenting on the
american
people with disease
and drugs in over 200 medical schools
and mental hospitals a big program that
went on a long time supposedly closed
down
by the csi by the cia also the army was
involved but a lot of the the navy's
activities
the navy was just covered for the cia
but uh
experimenting on population centers with
whooping cough viruses with other kinds
of viruses
dragging a barge through san francisco
bay leaking a flu type virus
to measure that technique for crippling
a city
apparently using swine fever virus which
is very much
aid similar to wipe out the hog
population in cuba in 1961
you know you add these things up and we
have every reason to ask
if this is not either a deliberate or
or an experiment or testing or something
that's gone awry
done by the cia another possibility
the london times on the 11th of may had
an article
sourcing a high official in the world
health organization
who claims that they had documents he
brought out documentation apparently
that aids was triggered by
uh smallpox inoculation programs of the
world health organization
and presenting all kinds of massive
documentation the countries where it's
hit the worst
where where they had the massive
smallpox inoculations
and then of course once it you know
apparently takes on a life of its own
the history will have to judge some of
these things
uh horrifying as aids
is it primarily the victims the 25 000
who died in this country so far are
homosexuals and
and drug users introvert you know the
needle exchange
horrifying as this is nevertheless it's
limited to one segment of the society
and it's a drop in the bucket uh
compared to some of our major health
program problems uh what
800 000 people die each year from
smoking
related illnesses and there is no great
furor about that and that's 800 000 per
year
55 000 a year dying on the highways a
lot of them from drunken driving
you know accidents and problems and
there's no big furore about that
in millions of cancer cancer which is
also
uh at least to some extent human made or
produced um
from the pollution of the pollutions and
additives and preservatives
and the furor on aids uh it seems you
know it's clearly
now of course the argument is that well
it's potential
for growth you know there's 75 million
people that have it
in africa today and and you know like
numbers here and there'll be 10 or 15
million now
history will show us whether or not
that's true whether it
it spreads like that well these articles
you're talking about
then do they discount the stories that
aids started in africa
with and spread to the rest of the world
well the stories that i've read
indicate that africa and haiti were the
first places where
epidemics of aids were found and then
the male
homosexual and drug using population of
the
u.s so the speculation is that
if it was the product of some berserk
experiment
or some accidental thing like a smallpox
vaccination program going berserk
it was then imported to the
target population of gay men in the
u.s by someone who wanted uh to carry
out a vendetta
against them well this is the
speculation
that charge was raised uh by toss for
example
in in 1983 and and some of the
more extreme magazines here in the
states brought it up and i
that struck me as cheap shot stuff uh
for one thing the cia simply was not
uptight about homosexuality the fbi was
because hoover was a closet homosexual
of the kind that that you know would
would roll
other homosexual persecuted other
homosexuals and the fbi
uh he had it very uptight about its
homosexuality the cia
just simply wasn't a big factor and
certainly
not enough for the cia to become you
know to launch a complicated
perhaps uncontrollable program to
exterminate
gays what about renegade factions of
either the cia
or the state department who heard that
there was some
virus that was used in some sort of
chemical warfare that had been tested
in africa and was found in haiti and
found to be highly
effective and some renegades got their
hands on this
and used it as a sort of berserk
vendetta is there any plausibility in
this kind of scenario
i have grave problems with it
uh in the cia and the state department
although you know if a renegade faction
could be two or three individuals you
know who knows
the the segment of society that has
delighted the most
of course is nixon's moral majority the
jerry falwell you know it's
clearly god's punishment and uh
you know whether they would have had
someone who could have brought out a
disease
this is pure speculation
and and i must say the kind that does
not uh
draw me so much because we have so much
i mean you have to keep your mind open
to possibilities like that because so
much stuff has come out
where we were saying now i couldn't be
or not likely and then later on you find
absolutely they were doing it the
experimentation on population centers i
remember when i saw the movie
coma back in i think it was the early
60s
and i i i kind of irritated you know
such fantasy such nonsense someone goes
into a hospital and
they wind up in a ward down in the
basement and they're kept on drugs and
experimented with disease and they
finally escaped
and never happen in this country maybe
in hitler's germany or something
and then i find out the mk ultra thing
that exactly that was done in over 200
medical schools and mental hospitals
what is mk ultra i don't recall that
that was the program the ci's program
for
for
under the technical services division to
experiment on
on population centers with disease and
drugs
and what years was this it started in
the 50s and lasted
until the 70s when jack anderson began
to expose it
and then the media caught on to it the
congress investigated
and the ci by the way destroyed
thousands of files
of victims people it had you know
experimented upon so they could never
get their files ensued
and supposedly it was stopped except it
was such a broad program that there was
never any one
bill that said stop this it was just
that the exposure
made everybody presume that the thing
would be stopped
and i i i
i you have to be very troubled and very
skeptical not one person was punished
that one person involved lost a paycheck
or was censored or was fired or much
less jailed
for those you know for the
experimentation on american citizens
with disease and drugs
in the meanwhile i ain't going to share
my needle with you anymore
yeah no that the the needle usage and
homosexuality
is clearly uh uh
that's not a fantasy that's not a myth
that's something where
where gays should take every precaution
and drug users are just inviting
self-destruction by using the needles
and there's so many
questions about this thing that i would
advocate
caution but i would also you know
very much like to get inside fort
dietrich's files and see
what evidence there might be